so in the midst of so many negative and
horrible things happening around the
world i'm going to take just a brief
break for something that's admittedly
not that important in the grand scheme
of things i mean listen we've got
ukraine
we have a shaky economy when it comes to
the stock market and inflation although
jobs numbers are good we have the
resurgence of covid again i mean it yes
it's it's happening again all these
different things i get that what i'm
about to tell you is not of utmost
importance but it's nice to have
something good going on
the david pakman show youtube channel
has achieved and surpassed
1.45 million subscribers meaning we are
now pushing
very close to a million and a half
subscribers okay
now i know
mr beast
xqc
pokemane you know these are major
streamers that make our numbers look
small but we're not in their space okay
we're in the independent left media
political space and 1.5 million
subscribers in that space is actually a
really big deal you've got the young
turks our friends at the young turks
with over 5 million subscribers
incredible achievement
they're a dramatically larger
organization than us at one point i
think they had close to 100 employees i
don't know where they are right now but
orders of magnitude different size
organization than the david pakman show
we're tiny in comparison and yet
we are riding up to being only the
second show
in the left media space to hit the
milestone of 1.5 million it's the young
turks
and then
in theory it could be us if we get there
we're not putting anybody down
right i mean
if you just look around you look at
other people in our space you've got a
bunch that are over a million you've got
some just under some closer to 500 000.
right now there is one major left
youtube show over a million and a half
and that's the young turks
if and when we get there we would be the
second so this is hugely exciting and
based on recent growth we're sort of on
target to hit 1.5 million about a month
before the midterms it'd be right in the
first half of october is the way it's
looking right now however
it's not impossible that we could do it
way more quickly right now we're about
45 000 youtube subscribers away from a
million if we wanted to hit that
milestone
by the summer equinox june 21 we would
need about a thousand subscribers a day
we've done that at other other times
usually it's like right before a
presidential election but it's not
inconceivable that we could do that even
just to hit by september 1st that shaves
about 40 days off
we only need about 400 subscribers a day
that's very very doable it's only
slightly faster than we're tracking
right now it is wild to look at old
numbers and to see how far we've come
the david pakman show launched on
youtube
uh in 2009
thanks to jenk yuger many people don't
know the story but in 08 i met jenk at a
talk radio conference because at the
time
talk radio was still big doing youtube
was the weird thing
and i met jenk and he said i told him
what i was doing at the time we were
doing a podcast and a radio show and he
said i would figure out just film
figure out how to film and um
see what happens
and it took us five years to get our
first hundred thousand subscribers
it took five full years just to get to
that first milestone
and then the next hundred thousand took
only a year and five months and then the
next hundred thousand was even quicker
and it's crazy that now
we might be able to add 45 000
subscribers in just a couple of months
and hit this insane milestone of a
million and a half subscribers so i
can't thank you enough everybody if
you're in that 1.45 million right now
thank you
and i'm coming to you for help and ideas
first make sure that you're subscribed
and second if you have ideas of how else
we might be able to accelerate the
milestone write in and let us know info
davidpakman.com i'm always up for doing
something extra something exciting and
people said at a million i should bleach
my hair blonde but we never got it in
place it was like we were at like 9.90
when someone suggested it i don't know
that anybody really cares about that
i would be up for that and i would be up
for filming it if it was interesting
we'd have to put a challenge on it right
like if we make it to the 1.5 million
by august 1st or something like that but
i'm up for whatever people want to write
in info davidpakman.com so let me know
your ideas we'll get something in place
and very very exciting stuff not the
most important thing in the world i
understand but with so many negative
things going on it's nice to have
something positive going on